welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Spider-Man across the
spider-verse ended with a brutal far
from home homecoming with no way home
spoiler warning before
of the many beautifully designed
universes of this film the most gripping
is the one that we end the film trapped
inside of Earth 42. turns out the number
42 wasn't just a random number on Mao's
spider or a number that followed him
around on his jersey the Clutter numbers
on the sidewalk nods to Jackie Robinson
and The Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy
but really the number of The Nightmare
Dimension that was waiting for him all
this time a nightmare of his own making
I'm gonna break down what Earth 42 is
its timeline and how our miles next move
against his alternate Prowler self is
not what you think and was hinted at
earlier in the movie if you were paying
attention now I broke down the 2018 into
the spider-verse for dozens of new
details and hosted a live stream of
across the spider-verse on the Deep dive
Channel subscribe and support us with a
Miles Morales Multiverse dive shirt at
nerdriot.shop in case you missed it new
rock stars isn't just one channel
anymore it's three earlier this year we
launched the Deep dive where I dig into
the deeper meaning behind everything you
love and our newest channel the break
room is where all of your nerdy friends
are gonna hang out online it's also the
new home for inside Marvel and all of
our reactions to the latest trailers TV
shows and movies we've got so many cool
videos planned so head on over and
subscribe and while you're at it don't
forget to subscribe to the new
Rockstar's main Channel and the Deep
dive okay and across the spiderverse we
learned that the spider that bit miles
Alka makes spider number 42 got that
number from the fact that it came from
Earth 42 and was brought to 1610 by
alchemic scientist Jonathan own the guy
who got hit in the head with a bagel and
was exposed to Dark Matter from the
collider and became the spot according
to Owen's backstory this spider was
native to Earth 42 and got transported
to 1610 right before it was going to
bite a student in a classroom based on
that uniquely braided hair that is Earth
42 miles G Morales the one our miles
meets in the final sequence this is a
huge deal because it tells us that this
anomalistic spider wasn't intended for a
Peter Barker but for a Miles Morales
Earth 42 was never going to have a Peter
Parker Spider-Man only a Miles Morales
Spider-Man and a miles that went to
school and for all we know was a good
kid this spider getting extracted by the
collider and transported to 1610 messed
everything up it doomed to earth 42. now
that's not our miles's fault despite
what Miguel O'Hara says it was really
1610 Kingpin and his alchemix scientists
including own who hijacked Earth 42's
spider and that spider just sought out
the closest thing to its miles to bite
and that just happened to be 16 10 miles
and ironically it bit Miles when he was
doing some goofish with Uncle Aaron
not when he was in school like his
Gallant variant was Earth 42 miles pays
attention in class for 16 10 miles
turned his book assignment into graffiti
but why did the spider Target a miles
and not a Peter to begin with well
that's probably something to do with the
web of life and Destiny my friends and
the whole spider-verse needing one miles
to prove the whole system according to
Miguel O'Hara's interpretation is messed
up and corrupt I think that's what
across the spider-verse and next year's
beyond the spiderverse will prove to be
all about we need to think beyond the
spiderverse and why forcing every spider
person through a prescription order of
Canon events is actually horrible and
destabilizing but in this movie's final
Act we see how that spider swap altered
the comparative trajectories and
timelines of 1610 and 42 1610 saw
Kingpin get arrested his cronies
thwarted and alchemex's collider Rex
this movie's First Act returns to that
collider site divided undergoing an
environmentally safe cleanup operation
and miles's parents Jeff and Rio are
still alive and doing well uncle Aaron
rests in peace and Brooklyn seems to be
a relatively safe space aside from a few
villains of the week Earth 42 meanwhile
is rough a Bizarro world in the vein of
1985 B from Back to the Future 2. miles
accidentally travels here after they go
home machine scanned its DNA and
detected the spider DNA the screen
reading Earth 42 and Miles was sent here
by mistake now to be clear miles still
glitches in this reality so the rest of
his DNA is still grounded in 1610.
really miles just has the shared DNA of
42 and 1610 but in this very first shot
of Miles Landing in Earth 42 on a rainy
and red and green lit rooftop on nearby
building is the number six which I think
could be a sign pointing to the Sinister
Six cartel that runs this place there's
also a sign for 42 Sushi and signs all
over pointing to different members of
the Sinister Six vulture Telecom and
then in Times Square there's a WWE sign
instead of Eminem and soda coca when in
1610 it's coca soda and then there's a
sign for two 2G cell coverage from
electro just 2G not 4G or 5G 2G The
Sinister Six cartel is doing everyone
with crappy cell coverage hey kick bad
habits to the curb let good habits into
your life and say hello to fume bad
habits are bad good habits are good so
why not just remove the bad from your
habit fume is an Innovative
award-nominated device that does just
that instead of electronics fume is
completely natural instead of vapor fume
uses flavored Air instead of harmful
chemicals fume uses all natural
delicious flavors you get it instead of
bad fume is good it's a habit you're
free to enjoy it makes replacing your
bad habit easy Doom comes with an
adjustable airflow dial and is designed
with movable Parts magnets it's super
fidgety which is perfect for
de-stressing and anxiety while breaking
your bad habit using a fume is like
having a breath of fresh minty air
coming out of a world-class fidget toy
that looks like it came from a schmancy
gift shot stopping a bad habit is
something we've all put off because it's
hard but switching to fume is easy over
100 000 people have used fume to
successfully break out of bad habits and
now you can do head to tryfume.com and
use code new rock stars to save 10 off
when you get the journey pack today
that's try fum.com and use code new
rockstars to save an additional 10 off
your order today then in Miles bedroom
gone are his 1610 toys and posters and
fun kid stuff instead our grimy milk
crates and a speed bag Rio asks why
miles took out his braids around Rio's
house there's hardly any photos to show
Jeff Rio's still doing miles's laundry
and working overnight shifts to take
care of him though so that's one hopeful
constant across the universe is a
mother's love and you may notice the
color scheme of Earth 42 tends to be
green and purple it's especially
pronounced in miles's bedroom and then
as he transitions to the rooftop the
green stairwell light going into the
purple Skyline outside when 1610 Peter
first saw miles in the 2018 film he saw
him with a green and purple Aura the
villainous colors of Green Goblin and
remember Norman Osborne wore green and
purple hobo sweats and no way home and
now miles is back in that green and
purple world that he would have stayed
in had Peter not seen that red and blue
goodness in him but I think it's
important to note that in Aaron's
apartment the color is casting light
over everything are red and blue which
is actually in this world a noble color
but then on the rooftop this purple lit
city is covered in neon signs one of
them Hammerhead then a green and yellow
sign that looks like Scorpion or Scorpio
Aaron's phone lights up and he side eyes
miles probably a text from Earth 42
miles that he's on his way home and then
when miles is ko'd by Prowler he
collapses with his dad's memorial mural
framed perfectly behind him then inside
Aaron's apartment when miles sees Earth
42 Prowler miles he lands in front of
the TV where we hear the voice of JK
Simmons J Jonah Jameson reporting the
so-called Sinister Six cartel So based
on these Clues The Sinister Six cartel
in Earth 42 includes at least the
vulture Electro Hammerhead scorpion and
a few others could be Norman Osborne
Goblin could be Doc could be Kingpin or
any number of other Spider-Man villains
because remember before miles Was Bitten
16-10 Peter Parker had battled plenty of
villains and locked them up but in Earth
42 no Spider-Man means criminals had
nothing standing in their way other than
poor Jeff Morales and it sounds like
there Corruption of the city has been
through low-grade consumer technology
and telecommunication like remember that
cop car that miles ran into was being
driven by a cop staring at his
smartphone but my question here is if
they send Sinister Six cartel had such
control over the city why would Aaron
and Earth 42 miles Prowler need to sneak
around if they were also criminals like
waiting for a security guard shift
rotation despite the nightmarish tones
it's not for sure that Aaron in 42 miles
are evil they might just be rugged
survivalists trying to get by working
outside the law and if that law is the
cartel they might actually be good guys
trying to bring the cartel down remember
that spider was trying to bite this
universe's miles it might have sensed
something good in him but remember that
advice that 1610 Miles mother Rio gave
him she said quote for years I've been
trying to take care of this little boy
right making sure he's loved that he
feels like he belongs wherever he wants
to be he wants to go out in the world
and do great big things and what I worry
about most is that they won't root for
you like us so here's the deal wherever
you go from here you have to promise to
take care of that little boy for me make
sure he never forgets where he comes
from that he never doubts that he's
loved and that he never lets anyone at
those big fancy places he's gonna be in
tell him that he doesn't belong there
and when he come comes home and he
better come home you're gonna be early
and you're going to be holding a normal
nice cake she talks about miles in the
third person to his face making a
promise not to take care of him
but promise to take care of that little
boy for me that little boy is Miles G
Morales from Earth 42. the little boy
who's supposed to be Spider-Man but
never got that chance and still I
believe might be a Prowler trying to do
the right thing in a Sinister Six cartel
dominated universe so Miles mission in
the next movie might not be to destroy
his variants but to be the brother to
him that the spider Society failed to be
for him hey a reminder to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive also
subscribe to the break room and support
us by grabbing some merch at nerd
riot.shop follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at EA boss follow new rockstars
And subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
thank you
foreign
[Music]